[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale nous sommes le mardi 10 mai voici
les titres
simone veil -le un destin une exposition
pour commémorer le cinquième
anniversaire de sa disparition
réalisé par le mémorial de la shoah son
inauguration a lieu à ce mardi 10 mai à
montigny le bretonneux au programme sa
vie ses combats nous revenons également
sur l'histoire de la faculté de médecine
de montigny le bretonneux et qui porte
son nom
rendre accessible le sport aux jeunes
c'est l'objectif de l'association frei
qu elle travailla pas liée à l'inégalité
des chances des disciplines parfois
onéreuses comme le golf ou encore
l'équitation présentation dans ce
journal et puis la 8e édition des golden
blog c'était de passage à guillon pour
ce week end une première dans les
yvelines un concept créé par le champion
du monde d'athlétisme ladji doucouré
pour soutenir les quartiers populaires
le principe être le plus rapide sur un
sprint de 50 m en face à face
[Musique]
je vous en parle et on titre
l'inauguration a lieu ce soir
l'exposition itinérante simone veil là
un destin 1927 1900 en 2006 est pardon
1927 2017 elle rendra hommage à simone
veil -le une figure emblématique du
combat des femmes et elles se déroulent
jusqu'au 18 juin 2022 ce sera à la
médiathèque du canal de saint quentin en
yvelines le reportage de céline charles
icône de la lutte pour les droits des
femmes ministres de la santé à qui l'on
doit la loi veil sur la dépénalisation
de l'avortement ou encore cinquième
femme à entrer au panthéon simone veil
est une des personnalités préférées des
français la médiathèque du canal de
saint quentin en yvelines a décidé de
lui rendre hommage à travers
l'exposition simone veil -le un destin
1927 2010 est créé à l'origine par le
mémorial de la shoah cette exposition
retrace son parcours depuis sa jeunesse
à
cette expérience dans les camps à
auschwitz et son parcours de magistrats
tf1 politique du 20e siècle ce qu'on ne
savait pas forcément c'est qu'elle
voulait être avocate que son mari a un
fusil mais ce n'était pas une confession
convenable pour les fermes à l'époque
elle a quand même souhaité à travailler
a poursuivi une carrière de magistrat
elle a pu faire un tour de france des
prisons et améliorer certaines des
conditions de vie dans ces prisons on a
une exposition retrace également ma
toute l'histoire de
de la guerre de l'occupation et la
déportation des juifs en france et on a
souhaité la présenter cette année
puisque en 2022 en juillet on commémore
les 80 ans des rafles une exposition
également axé sur la transmission un
rôle culturel d'information et de
sensibilisation que la médiathèque prend
à coeur on a aussi des actions en
direction de scolaires avec des
médiateurs du mémorial de la shoah
qui seront présents et qui accueille
rodez classe de
cm1-cm2 3e au collège et lycée pour
présenter l'exposition proposé de
travailler
autour d'ateliers
autour de la thématique objectif c'est
de donner les clés de compréhension du
monde d'aujourd'hui pour mieux vivre
ensemble et mieux construire ensemble
mende avant une exposition tout public
illustré de nombreuses photographies et
citations qui se déroulera jusqu'au 18
juin 2022 et dans quelques instants
justement nous aurons avec nous en
plateau djillali annane fin en plateau
en visio djillali annane doyen de l'ufr
à santé simone veil -le de lui vécu
et puis avec on va passer à autre chose
pour l'instant un cookie 1 euro pour
l'ukraine c'est une opération solidaire
lancée en soutien aux ukrainiens un
événement organisé par le département et
ce midi le gestionnaire des cantines des
collèges dont les yvelines jeudi 12 mai
des cookies préparé par les chefs de ce
midi est de 28 collèges évinois seront
en vente à un euro ça se passera pendant
les pauses ou à la sortie des cours
objectif récolter des dons l argent sera
reversé à l'association de soldes de
solidarité internationale acted liste
des établissements concernés à retrouver
sur le site du département
et cela fait plusieurs années qu'ils
travaillent en étroite collaboration
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines vient de renouveler l son
partenariat avec le cnrs pour cinq ans
de plus un accord qui profite aux deux
parties il vise à pousser la recherche
encore plus loin patrick jacques de
dixmude et c'est une charles
c'est signé le partenariat entre
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et le centre national de la
recherche scientifique continue pour
cinq ans de plus mardi 9 mai les deux
présidents se sont rencontrés sur le
campus des sciences à versailles pour
officialiser le renouvellement c'est la
confirmation du lien étroit qui entre
cet organisme national de recherche et
puis les équipes de recherche de l'ue vs
cul et c'est un contrat qui va sur une
durée de cinq ans qui affirment ces
politiques là et qui est aussi un cadre
juridique et financier de cet accord ici
parce que il y à des laboratoires de
qualité pour nous ça c'est la règle
absolue et donc on va visiter cet après
midi trois laboratoires en maths en
chimie en matériaux qui sont
d'excellents laboratoire avec des du
rayonnement international dans la
quinzaine de laboratoires de
l'université concernée un tiers du
personnel vient du cnrs un tiers de
l'université et un tiers d'autres
partenaires un accord équilibré qui vise
à développer la recherche dans de
nombreux domaines la chimie donc sur
laquelle
l'université et des partenaires très
fort et une visibilité internationale
que nombreuses années la chimie des
matériaux c'est un laboratoire plus
petit mais qui est sur une niche
d'excellence donc très précise mais qui
est reconnu là dessus et un laboratoire
de mathématiques us qu à mettre un peu
de moyens scénariste va mettre un peu de
moyens peut-être un troisième partenaire
met un peu de moyens et à la fin on a un
environnement qui va nous permettre non
seulement d'attirer des très bons
chercheurs des travaux chercheuse mais
aussi de garder une recherche conjointe
qui se veut innovante et
interdisciplinaire les deux partenaires
ambitionnent de développer encore plus
leur collaboration pour permettre aux
chercheurs de relever les défis
scientifiques économiques technologiques
et sociétaux qui les attendent à le golf
le tennis et l'équitation se sont ad
sport onéreux dans tout le monde n'a pas
forcément accès c'est cette inégalité a
des chances que l'association champoux
vienne chante l'ouvèze pardon ferait qu
a voulu casser les explications de
mathilde de francs cela fait deux ans
que assia nourine et saoussen peut
fouler la piste et pratiquer leur
passion grâce à la fondation gouesnac'h
us et l'association chante l'ouvèze
fraternité pour l'égalité des chances
une soixantaine de jeunes accèdent à des
sports comme le golf le tennis et
l'équitation au moins je suis
d'abord une habitante de championne
depuis 31 ans mère célibataire de trois
enfants trois garçons je connais un peu
la situation des enfants des quartiers
il y avait un besoin
al'approche signalé vers six jeunes là
et d'en parler d'autre chose et lui
sortir aussi 2 2 lors de leur domaine
leur quartier quoi le ramener son autre
chose qui ne connaissent pas c'est ça
l'idée en fait c'est des activités
sportives sont essentiels au
développement et à l'épanouissement de
l'enfant elle peut parfois coûter très
cher alors pour que la pratique sportive
soit équitable la fondation one à russe
soutient financièrement les familles moi
personnellement c'était mon rêve de
tarification et c'était très cher donc
avant je pouvais pas on a fait une année
et la deuxième année on pouvait pas et
mais j'ai quand même fait et j'aime
beaucoup le contact avec le cheval qu'on
a quand le brosse qu'on est sur son dos
qui aller coûte oui elle a entré les
traits comtois et contre tous les
contours les très très content la demo
moi j'ai passé ma vie avec mes cheveux
outre les acquis sportif l'équitation
permet également aux jeunes de sortir de
leur zone de confort et d'évoluer au
sein de la société mois l'évolution je
la vois surtout sur leur comportement
le
nurse jackie technique c'est autre chose
mais c'est surtout leur comportement
parce que certains enfants n'ont pas de
cadre familial alors certains sont bien
cadré d'autres ne sont pas assez cadré
donc on arrive ici nous on fait un peu
la police et un petit peu géré on fait
un peu office d'éducateurs quoi de plus
en plus l'association tresques ouvre son
champ de compétences à des activités
culturelles comme des ateliers d'arts
plastiques de théâtre ou encore de chant
elle anime également des cours pour
apprendre le français et le numérique
aux parents qui le souhaitent en
politique à présent avec une page les us
native et les premiers candidats de la
nouvelle union populaire écologiques et
sociales qui ont été désignés dans le
département des yvelines les
circonscriptions ont été répartis entre
eux à différents mouvements de gauche et
la france insoumise sera présente dans
huit circonscriptions europe écologie
les verts sera présent dans trois
circonscriptions le parti socialiste
aura le territoire historique où michel
rocard a occupé un siège à l'assemblée
nationale c'est la 7e circonscription
comme candidats invités sous la bannière
commune de la gauche on peut citer
benjamin lui qu'un coordinateur national
du mouvement générations point s
williams martinez ou encore sébastien
ramage dans la première circonscription
il était d'ailleurs ce matin dans
l'émission paf on écoute moi en tout cas
je m'engage à défendre avec la même
force et la même vigueur ma candidature
ou celle du parti socialiste sur la 7e
circonscription des yvelines celle de
génération sur laon la 8e
circonscription des yvelines parce que
nous nous sommes mis d'accord sur un
programme globalement au niveau national
les projections sont très bonnes et nous
nous nous fixons comme objectif et nous
disons aux électeurs électrices qu' il y
a une vraie possibilité de gagner ni
andy lally anna nous était avec nous
bonsoir
vous êtes doyen la paire santé simone
veil l'a alves qu alors juste pour ceux
qui viennent de nous rejoindre c'est
parce qu'on parlait de simone veil et
notamment de ce cinquième anniversaire
de sa disparition
je voulais rebondir tout à l'heure du
coup sûr sur votre fonction notamment
l'ufr santé simone veil pourquoi avoir
donné ce nom en 2012 quel est le lien
avec simone veil
en 2012 lorsque notre communauté a
réfléchis à quel nom devait donner à
notre nouvelle faculté on a lancé une
grande enquête auprès des étudiants et
des enseignants ces manuels et arriver
de loin le premier pour une raison très
ça c'est que globalement chacun a
considéré notamment que son action pour
la lutte contre l'avortement clandestin
et sa loi sur le lit vg a probablement
constituer
la plus grande avancée en matière de
santé publique du xxème siècle en france
c'est vraiment la mesure qui a
radicalement changé la santé des femmes
au cours du 20e siècle en particulier en
france et 7 5 a motivé le fait qu'on lui
donne cantonne à d'autres ufr le nom de
lendl et quand on lui a fait la demande
elle a accepté l'accepter d'emblée très
simplement et on a eu cette immense
chance et un honneur d'avoir seaman
belle en personne lors ce qui était je
crois sa dernière sortie officielle
venir inaugurer notre nouvelle faculté
de médecine et venir partager avec nous
un moment extrêmement important on la
voit à lampes led ici avec marisol
touraine qui est émise de la santé à
l'époque justement je vais rebondir là
dessus on vous parlait d'interruption
volontaire de grossesse qui était
présenté en 1974 est-ce que selon vous
il ya eu pour simone veil un avant et un
après cette loi
je crois qu'il ya eu pour les femmes en
france un avant et un après s'être
d'abord parce que elle avait tellement
de ferveur et de conviction à contre
courant contre à peu près tout le monde
réussit à imposer ce cette avancée
majeure et d'une certaine façon ça a
contribué à changer la façon dont la
femme était vu et perçu dans notre
société et on voit aujourd'hui si on
regarde ce qui se passe outre atlantique
aux états unis on voit à quel point
cette ce droit que la femme de disposer
de son corps reste y compris dans les
plus grandes oak racing comme aux
etats-unis quelque chose de très fragile
et il faut pas grand chose pour revenir
en arrière
en 2019 les étudiants justement de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines ils ont reconstitué ses débats
relatifs à liv et g est-ce que c'est
important de transmettre finalement cet
héritage c'est fondamental la
transmission du savoir est une des
leçons que à titre personnel j'ai tiré
de madame t il et de son action l'action
était fondée sur la transmission
transmission de l'horreur qu'elle a vécu
enfant dans les camps de concentration
transmission ensuite de son savoir de
son savoir-être de ses réflexions de sa
pensée sur ce que doit être une société
moderne en matière de droits droits des
personnes droit des femmes droits des
enfants et puis on suit ensuite son
action au niveau de l'europe
la record a été un élément fondamental
est toujours ancré sur cette grande
valeur qui à la transmission transmettre
aux futures générations
transmettre de génération en génération
c'est la meilleure façon pour nos
sociétés
d'aller de l'avant sans oublier le passé
qui fondent notre présent et pav le
chemin de votre avenir peut-être une
dernière question avant de vous laisser
c'était donc la première femme
secrétaire du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature première femme ministre de
la santé première présidente du
parlement européen finalement c'était
une pionnière en fait ça a été toujours
une pionnière elle est vraiment été
guidé par
une clairvoyance absolument
exceptionnelle une capacité à anticiper
et a trouvé d'emblée les chemins qu'il
fallait prendre et je crois que c'est
elle a ouvert tellement de route dans
notre société tellement de chantier
qu'on peut vraiment considérer peut-être
avec marie curie que c'est probablement
les deux plus grandes femmes
que la france a connu c'est c'est deux
dernières centenaire
et d'ailleurs elle a été à a été au
panthéon c'est la cinquième femme à y
être merci beaucoup djillali annane
d'avoir été avec nous et je le rappelle
vous êtes doyen de l'ufr santé simone
veil ubuesque merci beaucoup s'est
insurgé
samedi 7 mai on va passer à un sport à
présent c'était la huitième édition des
golden blocks elle est passée par la
place du marché à guyancourt une grande
première pour les yvelines lancé par le
champion du monde à d'athlétisme ladji
doucouré le concept est simple réaliser
un sprint de 50 m en face à face sans
chrono un reportage de mathilde de
franck où est michael et demi d'euros
des sprints et des sourires ce samedi 7
mai à vue en cours la ville a accueilli
la 8e édition des golden blog sur sa
place du marché le but réaliser une
course de 50 m en face à face sans
chrono un concept créé en 2014 par le
champion du monde d'athlétisme ladji
doucouré pour soutenir les quartiers
populaires en créer une espèce de
compétition caravane on va détecter des
enfants de 8 à
à 20 ans maintenant par catégorie d'âge
et de sexe et on essaie d'amener les
meilleurs de chaque quartier sur paris
en fait on essaye de faire en sorte que
les meilleurs de chaque quartier sa
fronde et devient le meilleur à la
lumière de la france tout simplement cet
événement est une grande première sur le
territoire des yvelines séduit par le
concept du en cours n'a pas hésité à
organiser ce rendez vous qui se rendra
dans 28 communes de france dans les
prochaines semaines en général
l'athlétisme on a besoin de grands de
grands équipements des stades et
gymnases pour courir lancer sauter et là
on vient tout à fait au coeur des
quartiers ici aujourd'hui ont conduit
routoirs au total plusieurs centaines de
jeunes ont pu s'essayer sur ce 50 m dos
à la mer possible pour tous
on s'amuse bien
[Musique]
tout le monde aura apprécié la course
d'ailleurs j'étais contre une fille j'ai
mis toute ma force pour courir parce
qu'après la force est bien dans tp les
grands gagnants de cette journée se sont
qualifiés pour la grande finale
nationale golden blocks un événement
programmé à l'automne
et juste avant de refermer ce journal
nous avons appris aujourd'hui la
disparition de jean loup gris maire de
gaillon assure mention il est décédé
possiblement d'un arrêt cardiaque
dimanche 8 mai maire de la ville depuis
2008 mais aussi vice-président de la
communauté urbaine grand paris seine et
oise il s'est éteint à l'âge de 60 ans à
nos pensées se tournent vers ses proches
et son entourage et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
ne ratez pas à dans un instant votre
magazine culturel présenté par célia
kgaa tsongo très bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]